the press has no trouble attacking the
first lady or the president of course
they're good at that but when he fights
back suddenly the First Amendment is in
peril
our Trump's attacks on the press really
an attack on our democratic norms Daily
Beast editor-in-chief and CNN political
analyst John Avlon seems to think so
we shouldn't normalize the spectacle
because it is a serious constant attack
at our democratic norms going after the
press going after individual entities
joining me now on this newest bout of
hyperbole is Fox News senior political
analyst Brit Hume his first time on the
Ingraham angle hi Brit how are ya Laurie
he got me up past my bedtime it's great
to see thank you for joining us so like
his art is our First Amendment in peril
because Donald Trump sent out that tweet
about CNN International and his comments
about fake news well something that
because of that tweet and I would say
broadly speaking that that trumps
criticisms of the media which have been
you know pretty consistent pretty pretty
frequent still haven't had it updated
with threaten our First Amendment
freedoms we in the media in this country
enjoy a level of freedom and protection
that is there is a rarely available
almost nowhere else on earth and we're
pretty invulnerable to government
officials and politicians the there's
not much they can do to us the the
Supreme Court is there to safeguard our
rights and has consistently done so to
the point where for example if someone
wants to sue for libel they have to
prove that the offending party has
committed either a reckless or a willful
act of falsehood that's pretty hard to
prove in my own career Laura I've been
spied on by the CIA I've been sued for
libel I've been criticized by name and
Here I am after all these years and
that's because we were protected in this
country that's just not much Donald
Trump can do to the media I was sued for
libel when I was 19
Brett at Dartmouth professor sued me I
learned a lot about the First Amendment
but ultimately unsuccessful but you're
right I was thinking about Obama
President Obama and you know he had a
seemingly very chummy relationship with
the with the mainstream press often
times but then we had the James Rosen
controversy sharyl Attkisson the
journalist said she was her computer was
actually hacked into his comments about
Fox News other supporters comments about
talk radio routinely belittling Fox and
in conservative Internet you know web
sites and so forth so I could I could
make the argument that in maybe a kind
of sophisticated way or not so
sophisticated in some way the Obama
administration was much more hostile to
an unfriendly critical press well I
would agree with that Laura I think that
you know what was done in the case of
James Rosen was grossly improper it
should not have happened it was an abuse
and yet in the end James Rosen was still
working on Fox News and doing better
than ever and cheryl atkinson is
certainly out there still we are just in
too well protected a position to be
knocked off by or thrown off throwing
off our work by government not only that
it's not just that we have these
protections but we in the media also
have power so we're we're we're pretty
safe
yeah sorry but it a lot of people in the
media especially CNN MSNBC they don't
want to be criticized they the idea that
anyone's going to call their wisdom and
into question or their prognostication
abilities and into question they don't
like that they never liked it they never
wanted to be called out not by other
media outlets Media Research Center you
know whether it's you know a website or
it's a talk right they don't like they
don't like that they want to be the
invulnerable invincible folks and I'm
talking about some of our other friends
on other networks I mean we're not we
don't always get it right but you know
you're not immune to criticism either
you can you can dish it out but you
can't take it I want to talk a
little bit about President Trump's
comment today at that code talkers
ceremony and play the soundbite let's
watch you were here long before any of
us were here although we have a
representative in Congress who they say
was here a long time ago
they call her Pocahontas but you know
what
I like you because you are special now
Brett I'm not sure why the president had
to bring up Elizabeth Warren I mean
we're not really in the campaign not in
2020 yet I mean maybe she's maybe it was
on his mind because of the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau issue I
don't know we're gonna handle that later
in the show but well what about that
moment going crazy I agree with you
Laura I don't think I don't think it was
a very gracious thing for him to do and
he does a lot of ungracious things grace
is not his strength you know he's done
generous to people he's constantly
carping about people who were much
smaller than he is I'm not sure what
that accomplishes but I don't think it's
a threat and I don't think it's racist
you know it your earlier segment brought
this to light as well that term is
flying around with abandoned today and
it is a tragedy because the great
achievement of the civil rights movement
greater even than the important laws
were passed with a consensus that it
brought about that racism is wrong and
not to be tolerated and an overwhelming
prohibitive majority of Americans feel
that way and for that turn to be flung
around with abandon is an abuse and
there's been much too much of it and I
you know I think that for a little
Lizabeth warned to call it a racist slur
is is unfair it's long she's a big girl
what he said is essentially harmless if
crude just my view that is just just
move on all right Brett I really
appreciate it I mean it's kind of funny
but it's probably not necessary I've
seen President Trump be incredibly
gracious toward people he is very
gracious and he's very you can put out
you can turn on the charm and he wants
to but there he had to hit the dig into
a well at least he didn't call her focus
on toast bread look at it look at it
that way it could have been it could
have been even up more more perhaps
ungracious I appreciate thanks so much